[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جموده
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
ابرز هذه الاحداث وفاه اسطوره كره القدم
البرازيلي
وهذه صور من صوت باولو
حيث ستكونوا لنا وقفه مع مراسلنا هناك
حسان مسعود بعد قليل
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
تركيا وسوريا وروسيا ومسار البحث عن
التوافقات عقبه اول اجتماع من نوعه بين
وزراء دفاع الدول الثلاث في
موسكورا لانهاء وجود ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه شماليه سوريا والتوافق على
اليه لتسهيل عوده اللاجئين السوريين وحديث
عن تشكيل لجان مشتركه تبدا العمل في موسكو
الشهر المقبل
للمره السادسه نتنياهو يتولى رئاسه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده
في سجل حكومه اسرائيل و بعد اعلان اولويه
توسيع الاستيطان في البرنامج الحكومي
الرئيس الامريكي يقول انه واشنطن ستواصل
دعم حل الدولتين وستعارض اي سياسه تهدد
امكانيه تحقيقه
من جديد استهدافهم روسي للمنشات الحيويه
في كييفو مدن اوكرانيه عده
مسيره اوكرانيه كانت تستهدف قاعده عسكريه
في عمق الاراضي الروسيه
داخل حدودها وتستدعي السفير الاوكرانيه
للاحتجاج
وكياف تقول انها لا تستبعد ان يكون سقوط
الصاروخي استفزازا روسيا متعمدا
وفي البرازيل وفات اسطوره كره القدم
اللاعب الوحيد الذي فاز بكاس العالم 3
مرات بعد صراع مع المرض
[تصفيق]
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تصريحاته ما بعد الاجتماع
السوري التركي في موسكو الذي حضره وزير
الدفاع البلدين الى جانب نظيرهما الروسي
حيث قالت مصادر تركيا للجزيره ان الاجتماع
اسفر عن اتفاقا على تشكيل لجان مشتركه
تبدا اجتماعاتها نهايه الشهر المقبل في
موسكو تاليها اجتماعات في انقره ودمشق كما
اشارت الى الاتفاق على اليه مشتركه لتسهيل
عوده اللاجئين السوريين بعد توفير الارضيه
المناسبه اضافه الى تصورا يضع حدا لوجود
ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في شمال
سوريا
في اي سياق تاتي الاجتماعات التركيه
السوريه
43% اعتبروها انعكاسا بعوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بينما قال ثلاثه
انها اجتماعات تجري بدوافع سياسيه هدف
يحين راى 24 في المئه انها تنسيق امني
عابر
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز
الظاهر على الشاشه
وتتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
في لبنان حصاد عام
واسئله عن الفراغ الرئاسي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان نخوض في اخبار السياسه
نتوقف عند خبر رحيل اسطوره كره القدم
النجم البرازيلي بالله عن عمر نهز اثنين
وثمانين عاما بعد صراع مع المرض ابنه
النجم بلا اكدت خبر وفاته عبر حساب على
انستغرام
من مستشفى اين مراسله الجزيره حسان مسعود
حسان ما هي المعطيات المتوفره حتى اللحظه
حول هذه الوفاه وحول مراسم الوداع
نعم
هذا الخبر المفجع بالنسبه للبرازيليين
والذي كانوا يترقبونه ويتمنون الا يحدث
بالفعل وهو رحيل اسطوره كره القدم
البرازيليه
عن عمر نهز 82 عاما هذا الاسطوره الذي
يلقب هنا في البرازيل بالملك ملك كره
القدم البرازيليه التي استطاع ان يحضر كاس
العالم للبرازيل ثلاث مرات عمى 58 و 62
عام 70 ولقب همم في ارشيف الفيف بانه اعظم
لاعب في كره القدم وكذلك حصل على لقب افضل
لاعب في القرن العشرين من قبل اللجنه
الاولمبيه رحل اليوم هنا في هذا المستشفى
المستشفى البرت اينشتاين سنشاهد هذه
صور المباشره الان التي تاتيكم على شاشه
الجزيره
لهذه الاجواء عند الدقائق الاولى بعد رحيل
اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه الذي اعلن عن
وفاته قبل ساعه عندما اكدت نجله او ابنه
همم الراحل اسطوره كره القدم
هذا الخبر معلنه همم انه رحل وان كل شيء
نحن فيه كما ذكرت في صورتها في السوره
التي نشرتها هو بفضل هذا الرجل همم هذا
هذه الوفاه اعلنت بعد ما كان قد وصل النجم
بلاي الى هذا المستشفى المستشفى البرت
اينشتاين في سو باولو قبل شهر من الان في
حاله
الصحافه قد تداولت عنها حاله صعبه واا انه
كان يخضع للعلاج همم الت في فقط دون اا
ال- اا القدره على التجاوب مع العلاج
الكيميائي الذي كان يعالج من خلاله بسبب
اصابته بمرض سرطان القولون هذا المرض الذي
كان قد اصابه في سبتمبر من عام 2021 عندما
همم خضع لعمليه جراحيه لاستئصال جزء من
القولون بسبب همم هذا الورم السرطني وكان
يخضع للعلاج تماثل حينها للشفاء عاد الى
حياته شبه الطبيعيه والتقى بعدد من محبيه
همم في مدينته سانتوس التي همم هي التي
تتحضر الان همم لاستقباله ولي اقامته
الجنازه على روحه في ملعب مدينه سانتوس
ملعب النادي الذي كان قد لعب به نجم
الكبير بليه لمده 18 عاما بشكل
تصل
وحقق فيه اكبر الانجازات في تاريخ هذا
النادي همم كان قد لعب في نادي سانتوس
وعندما كان قد
اقترب من الرحيل عن نادي سانتوس عام 58
واجرى عقدا مع نادي انتر ميلان همم
الايطالي قامت ما يشبه به الثوره في مدينه
سانتوس الساحليه في مدينه همم في ولايه
سوف باولو ل همم
رحيل اللاعب والنجم الكبير الراحل بلاي
وعاد الى هذا النادي ليواصل مسيرته
الكرويه هو همم يعتبر اسطوره كبيره
بالنسبه للبرازيليين وهذا هذه الوفاه اتت
قبل يومين فقط من همم الموعد المحدث
لتنصيب الرئيس البرازيلي المنتخب لولا ده
سيلفا وهو ما يثير الان حاله من الضبابيه
حول مصير هذا تنصيب حول واقع البلاد وموعد
اا الجنازه وكل هذه التفاصيل التي
سنتابعكم سنفيدكم بها فور صدورها ان شاء
الله شكرا لك حسان مسعود من سوفاوله
يترك اللاعب البرازيلي فيليه الذي توفي عن
82 عاما ارثا في فنون كره القدم قبل نظيره
في تاريخها فهو اللاعب الذي استطاع مع
رفاقه الفوز بكاس العالم ثلاث مرات وهو
صاحب الاهداف الاكثر من بين اللاعبين في
تاريخ البطوله الكرويه وصاحب الالقاب
الاكثر عالميا وفي بطوله امريكا الجنوبيه
وربما يكون مماثيره الكبرى في مسيرته
الرياضيه انه استطاع ادخال كره القدم الى
الولايات المتحده التي لم يكن لها ذكر
فيها
وقد نال لقب لاعب القرن بشركه مع اللاعب
الارجنتيني دييغو مارادونا تقرير فوزي
ما البطوله بطوله الفرد الذي يخرج من قاع
الحياه ليصعد الى قمه قممها في فن من
الفنون فيكون صاحب زمانه وسلطان فنيه
بطوله الفرد التي تبدو احيانا كما لو انها
طفره اجتماعيه تنتقب لها الظروف واحدا
ينهض بجماعته على نحو يصعب تفسير حدوثه
فما كيميائها وما سرها
في البرازيل حيث الفقر وما يرتبه من
عنصريه الاجتماعيه هي بقيه من تاريخ الرق
في البلاد صنعت الظروف للخيال الشعبي بطلا
يعوض عن بؤس الحياه ونؤم الفاقه وانحسار
المستقبل امام عيون الملايين من البشر
المعدمين
لم يكن البطل غير سبيل اسود اسمه
صعود غيره نجما في سماء البرازيل فلا مال
ولا طبقه ولا عرق يسعفه
لقد صعد الفتى بقدمه الساحرتين حتى ملئ
الافق البرازيلي لا يزاحمه عليه احد
البطل الفرد غالبا صنعه نفسه كان اراده
الله جاء به يضيء
الطريقا ملهمه
ومعزيا للذين تموت احلامهم في ازقه الحوار
الفقيره الولد الذي لم يتجاوز عمره 17
عاما سيعود بكاس العالم الى بلاده من
البطوله التي نظمتها السويد عام 58
يصير اسبوع على كل لسان ويبقى مصدرا
لمسرات السحن السوداء والبيضاء على السواء
اكبر من طاقه عمره الغد فلا يعرف اين يذهب
بهذه النجوميه خارج ملاعب كره القدم
ما كانت البرازيل تملك ما تفاخر به في
ستنيات القرن الماضي شيئا اكثر من كره
القدم
يعودون الى تتويج البرازيل مرتين اخرىين
بكاس العالم مره عام 62 في تشيلي والثانيه
في عام 70 في المكسيك فيكون بذلك وحيده
زماني الذي يحقق الفوز بالكاس ثلاث مرات
ان هذه النجوميه التي كان صيتها قد ملئ
الدنيا كانت خلال اكثر سنوات البرازيل
ديكتاتوريه بعد انقلاب العسكر في عام 64
على الحكم الديمقراطي
عاشت البلاد تحت حكم عسكريه لم يتردد في
قتل وتعذيب واخفاء معارضيه على مدى 20
عاما حكم دكتاتوريون استثمر على نحو ما في
نجوميه وشعبيه كانه منجزر عسكري
الناقدون سيره بيليه يقولون انه سكت حيث
ينبغي الكلام في وجه العسكر فلم يستغل
شعبيته ونفوده الكبير وصار الى حياه تام
تجاه ما يحدث في البلاد
وقد كشفت وثائق سريه حديثه عن تلك الفتره
النبي كانت تحت المراقبه من العسكر وانه
ربما كان قد تعرض لبعض الضوء اما بيليه في
يدفع عن نفسه تهمه الحياه بانه لا يفهم في
السياسه شيئا
في العام 75
سيترك بيليه البرازيل وفريقه سانتوس ليبدا
تجربه غايه في المخاطره والاثاره بانضمامه
الى فريق كوزموس النيويورك كي لكره القدم
وكره القدم لعبه لا تثير حماسه الامريكي
في شيء لان حماسته مرتبطه بلعبه الركب
العنيفه كانها التمثل بعنف اخر عنف متوحش
يتمظهر على نهر ماء في اللعبه الاكثر
شعبيه
لم يبقى بيليه عامين في كوزموس حتى جاءت
نجوميته بعشرات الالاف الى ملاعب كره
القدم خاصه بعد ان ينضم اليه نجوم كاس
العالم السابقون مثل هولندي كرويف
والالماني بكمباور والبرازيلي
اما الانجليزي الذين صنعوا كره القدم ثم
رموا بها العالم ستنتهي مهمتهم هنا
فسحرت كره القدم واساطينها الاتون من
امريكا الجنوبيه هم وحدهم من سيمنحون هذه
الكره معنا ان تكون فنا وان تكون موسيقى
الفن
[موسيقى]
قلت مصادر تركيه للجزيره دفاع سوريا
وروسيا وتركيا اتفقوا على تشكيل لجان
الدفاعيه واستخباراتيه مشتركه تبدا
اجتماعتها نهايه الشهر المقبل في موسكو
وبحسب المصادر ذاتها فان اجتماع موسكو
اتفق ايضا على اليه مشتركه لتسهيل عوده
اللاجئين السوريين بعد توفير الارضيه
المناسبه كما ناقش الاجتماعي تصورا يضع
حدا لوجودنا تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
شمال سوريا وفتح طرقات الدوليه وسماح
للبضائع التركيه بالمرور عبر الاراضي
السوريه
مسار في موسكو يخترق جهود العلاقات
التركيه السوريه اجتمع في العاصمه الروسيه
يوم الاربعاء وزراء دفاع روسيا وتركيا
وسوريا ورؤساء استخبارات الدول الثلاث
بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه نقشت في
الاجتماع غير المسبوق منذ سنوات سبل حل
الازمه السوريه ومشكله اللاجئين وجهود
محاربه الجماعات المتطرفه في سوريا
بالنسبه للجانب التركي فالخراط انقره في
الملف السوري متعدد الاوجه فمن ناحيه هناك
ملف لاجئين السوريين بكل تعقيداته وهناك
من ناحيه اخرى الاشتباك التركي مع مسلحي
الاكراد في الشمال السوري الذي يبقى
الهاجس الدفاعيا المصيطره على التمثيل
التركي في اجتماع موسكو
هدفنا الوحيد هو محاربه الارهاب وتحييد
التنظيمات الارهابيه لحزب العمال
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
وتنظيم الدوله نبذل جهود لمنع المزيد من
حركات اللجوء من سوريا الى تركيا كما
اكدنا على ضروره حل المساله السوريه
بطريقه شامله في اطار قرارات مجلس الامن
عقب الاجتماعي قالت مصادر تركيه للجزيره
ان الوزراء الدفاع الثلاثه اتفقوا على
تشكيل لجنه المشتركه تضم ممثلين دفاعين
واستخباراتين وتبدا اجتماعاتها نهايه
يناير المقبل في موسكو ثم تتوالى
الاجتماعات في انقره ودمشق بحث الاجتماعاه
وفق المصادر التركيه فتح الطرق الدوليه
والسماح للبضائع التركيه بالمرور عبر
الاراضي السوريه كما بحث تصورا يضع حدا
لوجود ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
شمال سوريا واتفق على اليه مشتركه لتسهيل
عوده اللاجئين السوريين بعد توفير ارضيه
مناسبه تقول تركيا ان النظ سوريا يرغب
بهذه العوده جاء هذا في تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه مولود شاو شغله الذي شدد على ان
تتم بشكل ايجابي مع ضمان سلامه اللاجئين
العائدين واشار الاجتماع اولي مرتقب مع
نظيره الروسي والسوري يعد خارطه طريق قبل
الترتيب لاجتماع رؤساء الدول الثلاث
سلامه اللاجئين السوريين اكد عليها لاحقا
وزير الدفاع التركي خلص
مشددا على عدم اقدام بلاده على اي عمل
يكون من شانه المساس بهم او بالسوريين
داخل تركيا او سوريا
على مهل تسير خطوات التطبيع بين انقر
ودمشق وهي تاتي عقبه تصريحات تمهيديه
سابقه من المسؤولين الاتراك كان الابرزها
حديث الرئيس التركي قبل اسبوعين عن اليه
ثلاثيه لتسريع المسار الدبلوماسيه بين
بلاده والجانب السوري
من موسكو نيكولاي سيرجي الاستاذ في معهد
العلاقات الدوليه الروسيه ومن اسطنبول
طوبه دم الاستاذه في جامعه بنر باتشات ومن
اسطنبول ايضا محمد سرميني مدير مركز جسور
للدراسات نبدا معك سيده
ماذا تريد تركيا
وعمليا ماذا تريد تركيا من هذا التقارب مع
دمشق واعاده فتح طريق التطبيع من جديد معه
انكره ياسمين
البلد الذي تاثر باكبر قدر ممكن سلبيا بعد
سوريا نفسها طبعا جرار الحرب الاهليه في
سوريا وكما تعلمون تركيا تستضيفه اكبر عدد
من اللاجئين الفرنسي السوريين الارقام
غير رسميه تقول نحو خمسه ملايين
اقتصاديه لاستضافه مثل هذا العدد ايضا
هناك مشاعر في تركيا قبيله للانتخابات
عاده حيث تقوم
الاحزاب المعارضه بشعل قضيه اللاجئين
واحده من اهم القضايا على جدتها مما دفع
الحكومه وحزمها الى اتخاذ خطوات دفاع
قبل الانتخابات في العام المقبل 2023 هذا
هو اهم مواعظ القلق التركيه لحل قضيه
اللاجئين كما اعلن الرئيس راتب طيب
اردوغان في الصيف بان تركيا تريد اعاده
التوطين مليون في المناطق الامنه داخل
سوريا بالطبع اذا كان هؤلاء راغبين
بالعوده لكن بالطبع سن العمليات العسكريه
عبر الحدود هو مكلف دائما والحوار هو
دائما اكثر راهنيه واكثر علاقه اذا بهذا
المعنى يمكن ان نقول ان تركيا تعود الى
اصل هذه
الامور وتجعل من شعاره سياستها الخارجيه
على اساس السلام اخر البلاد والسلام
خارجها
كجوهر واساس في
اجننتتها وتودع حلا هذه المشكله اللاجئين
بالتعاون مع سوريا قبل حلول لموقع
الانتخابات
روسيا من جانبها ماذا هدفت من وراء همم
جمع الطرفين
وما الذي قدم للنظام السوري ايضا كي همم
يقبل بالدخول في طريق التطبيع من جديد
الجو برشا
تطبيق العلاقات بين انقره دمشق لانه من
الاهميه
في دمشق والاعتراف فيها دوليا ان تبقى من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه ونعترف بها
الدوليا
مع تركيا الدول الاخرى وخاصه دول الخليج
ستحذو حظها تركيا وهذا امر مهم لروسيا
هناك ايضا المساله الكرديه لان
روسيا هي حديث طبيعي
لتركيا في التصدي للوجود الامريكيه في
سوريا
الكرديه في شمال سوريا سيد محمد سرميني
كيف تتوقع ان يكون انعكاس
هذا التقارب التركي السوري على المعارضه
السوريه
لا شك ان المعارضه السوريه وكثير من
السوريين يمرون في حاله القلق
اذا هذا التقارب ولكن اذا كان هذا التقارب
حقيقي اذا صاحب
ان اللقاء الذي حصل حصل في موسكو ولم يحصل
في دمشق وان الجانب التركي بشكل اساسي
معني بالحديث مع موسكو وليس من الحديث مع
النظام
وانما هذا اللقاء هو امتداد للمسار كان
منذ عده اعوام وهو مسار الاستيناء الذي هو
في مشاركه روسيه وتركيه وايرانيه من اجل
ايجاد حل وتفاهمات على ما يجري في سوريا
احدها هم هذه التفاهمات هي عوده اللاجئين
والتي دائما يركز عليها اجتماعات التي
تحصل في السيتانه بانه لابد من توفير بها
امنه وعوده امنا اللاجئين الامر الاخر
الذي يتم تركيز عليه هو انه لابد ايضا
مكافحه الارهاب هناك تهديد
يتمثل على الامن القومي التركي المتمثل في
وجود قوات انفصاليه كرديه موجوده في شمال
سوريا تريد تركيا ان تتاكد من ان هذه
القوات يتم اخصائها وابعادها وان تشكل
لديها عباره عن بيئه امنه ان تصبح سوريا
عموما بيئه امنه ليست مصدر تهديد بشكل او
باخر وهذا الامر ليس حديث عهد بالنسبه
لتركيا ان ما هذه المخاطر او هذه المخاوف
هي منذ منذ التسعينيات حيث هناك حصل في
عام 1998 اتفاقيه اضنه الذي من الذي على
اساسها تم السماح لتركيا بان تكون تتدخل
بحكم عمق خمسه كيلو متر من اجل السماح ل-
اا الغاء اي تهديد تمثيل هذه الانفصاليه
التي لم تذكرها سيده الدم من من اسطنبول
اشارتي اللاجئين اشارتي الى موضوع
الانتخابات لكن موضوع ما تعرب بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه كان يعني موضوعا رئيسا ايضا
في نقاشات الوزراء الثلاثه الروسي
والسوري
اين اصبحت هنا العمليه العسكريه اا
التركيه المزرعه في شمال سوريا وهل يمكن
ان يتم تعديلها او ارجائها او الغائها
نتيجه
لهذا الاجتماع
يسنجر
على الاقل
تاجيل العمليه لان تركيا قد سبق لها وان
قامت بعده عمليات عابره للحدود داخل سوريا
من اجل الحيلوله
تشكيل مناطق كرديه مستقله عن سوريا
فالحكومه
التركيه تتطلع قدما الى التعاوني مع
الحكومه السوريه فيما يتعلق بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه والحكومه السوريه بالمقابل
تريد من تركيا
من داخل الى الاراضي السوريه
واوضحت اثناء اللقاءات التي تجري في وزاره
في موسكو بان تركيا تنظر بشكل ايجابي الى
صاحب قواتها اذا ما استطاعت الحكومه
السيطره على هذه الاراضي هذا يجعلنا نشعر
بان هناك بصيصه امل من ان اي عمليه عسكريه
قد يصاروا الى تاجيرها لان الاطراف
الثلاثه سوريا وتركيا وموسكو في عقد هذه
اللقاءات وتجديدها في انقر لاحقا ودمشق
بعد ذلك
باختصار
روسيا هنا ما الذي سوف
تقدمه لتركيا في همم مقابل التراجع عن هذه
العمليه العسكريه او الغائها ربما كما
تقول السيد طوبه باختصار
شاكي
المجال الجوي السوري امام الطائرات
التركيه والسيارات التركيه اذا لان روسيا
ما تساقط تسيطر على هذه الاجواء ايضا
بامكان روسيا متابعه بالمزيد من القوات
الى شمال سوريا
وترتب لدوريات عسكريه مشتركه مع الجيش
التركي
ايضا وحتى الحكومه السوريه تفهم ذلك انه
من دون الاكراد يكون نصاب احتوائي تهديدي
عشوه بالطبع سوريا بامكان تقبل الله
لان اللاجئين ليس لهم
ان اعود الى الى النقطه الاولى التي سالت
بشان السيد همم سرميني وباختصار شديد كيف
سيكون همم مصير المعارضه المدعومه من
تركيا في ضوء هذا التقارب والتطبيع سيد
ترميني باختصار
يؤكد بان انه لا يكون هناك اي تاثير او
تغييرات على مصير سواء كان المعارضه
الموجوده في تركيا او حتى السوريين
الموجودين في مناطق في داخل الاراضي
السوريه باختصار هذا المسار المسار طويل
المسارات التي همم ذكرناها سابقا سواء كان
مسارات جنيه تحت الرعايه الاميه او مسارات
الثلاثيه في السيتانه لم تفضي الى شيء
حقيقه المسارات الاقتصاديه او اي الذهاب
لتطبيع العلاقات او تحسين العلاقات مع
النظام السوري للاسف شديد التجارب السنوات
12 ماضيه لم تحقق اين نتائج مرجوها صحيح
ان هناك اقليميه ودوليه وهي مفهومه لكن
هذا ليس بالتاكيد لن يؤثر على المسار
العام لدى المعارضه والسوريين موجودين في
سوريا
من اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لك همم
الدم استاذه في جامعه فناير باشا من
اسطنبول وشكرا لنيكولا يصير جو الاستاذ في
معهد العلاقات الدوليه الروسي كان معنا من
موسكو
[موسيقى]
صدق الكنيست الاسرائيليه على منحي الثقه
وتنصيب الحكومه الجديده برئاسه
وذلك
بثلاث 63 صوتا مقابل معارضه 55 ومن ابرز
الخطوط العريضه للائتلاف الحكومي الجديده
تعزيز الاستيطان وتوسيعه في الضفه الغربيه
وبالتزامن مع هذه التصريحات قال الرئيس
الامريكي ان ادارته ستستمر في دعم حلل
دولتين
وبالتفصيل
عودته الى سده الحكم التطرق الى وثيقه
خطوط حكومته العريضه
واختار الحديث اولا عن القضيه الجامعه بين
الائتلاف والمعارضه وهي محاربه
مشروعينا لذا ستكون مهمتنا الاولى التاكد
من ان ايران لن تقصفنا بقنابل ذريه
السابقه ووعد بالعمل من اجل العوده الى
الحكم
قوي وقدرات امنيه عاليه وقوه ردع هائله
ومكانه دوليه هي الافضل على الاطلاق
حاولوا لا تدمر هذا سنعود قريبا
كنيسه الثقه لتنصيب الحكومه الجديده وكى
يصل نتنياهو الى هذه المرحله كان عليه
استرضاء شركائه في احزاب اقصى اليمين
والمتدينين وتشريع قوانين جديده تلبس
شروطهم وتوجهاتهم السياسيه والدينيه
واحتجاجا على ذلك تظاهر 100 الاسرائيليين
خارج مقر الكنيست وطالبوا بعدم منح الثقه
للحكومه يقولون انها ستقود اسرائيل الى
دوله دينيه اصوليه
بدفع اثمان باهضه لبقائه في السلطه كي
يحمي نفسه من محاكمته في قضايا الفساد
المتهم بها
ضد الفلسطينيين وحقيقته كونها دوله احتلال
بالترويج انها دوله ديمقراطيه ولبراليه
لكن مع تنصيب حكومه توصف بالاكثر تطرفا
سياسيا ودينيا واجتماعيا ستزداد التحديات
امامنا ياهو بين سعيه للحفاظ على ائتلافه
الجديد وبين تسويق صوره اسرائيل
كدوله ديمقراطيه
فمع انطلاق هذه الحكومه عبر الفلسطينيون
عن قلاقهم من تزايد اعتداءات الاحتلال
وانتهاكه للشرعيه الدوليه لا سيما ان خطوط
الحكومه العريضه لا تخفي مخططاتها بتعزيز
الاستيطان وتوسيعه وتجديد قبضه الاحتلال
على مفاصل حياه الفلسطينيين
نقلت ايضا الصراع من كون صراع فلسطين
اسرائيلي الى صراع فلسطيني الى صراع
اسرائيلي دولي الان مع تحديها لقرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه خيارات حول التركيز على
رص الصفوف تحقيق المصالح الفلسطينيه
يؤكد الفلسطينيون ان ما سبق هذه المرحله
لم يكن بافضل لكنهم يخشون الامعانه اكثر
في القضاء على حلمهم بالتحرر واقامه دوله
فلسطينيه
نسوان سمري الجزيره مدينه القدس
مرحبا بك سيد محمد هل هذه الحكومه الجديده
منسجمه من الداخل بين احبابها اليمنيه
والدينيه المتطرفه
مع نزع اخذ بالتدين نزع التدين واضحه
وتاكيد على يهوديه الدوله كدين وليس قوميه
هو هذا تم التعبير عنه ايضا في الخطوط
العريضه الاتفاقيات
نحن نرى ان الحكومه تشكلت همم مع حضور
اكبر للمستوطنين حيث حيث هذا المستوطنون
في هذه الحكومه على ملفات وحقائب وزاريه
في غايه الاهميه من وزاره الماليه وزاره
التربيه والتعليم وزاره الامن همم القومي
وهمم السمه الاكثر وضوحا لهذه الحكومه ان
هنالك احتدام لا الصراع في اسرائيل بين
النقب التقليديه التي حازت على مفاصل
الحياه وعلى قصب الدوله العميقه في
الاكاديميا في جهاز القضاء في الاعلام وفي
الاقتصاد وامام النقب المضاده التي رفعت
راسها مؤخرا وطلبت باجراء تغييرات جوهريه
في جهاز الدوله وفي سياسات الدوله الحديث
عن ساسه اتو من اجل تغيير جوهري لهويه
الدوله و لمفهومها وجوهرها طيب هنا يطرح
سؤال طيب اذا كان برنامجها كما اعلن بهذا
التطرف
الكبير
والاكثر تشددا في تاريخ اسرائيل كيف
ستستطيع حكومه نتنياهو اا تطبيق هذا
البرنامج داخليا مع الحفاظ على علاقاتها
الدوليه والتزاماتها همم الدوليه الاخرى
يعني هذه الحكومه وضعت عنوان عريضا وهو
اغلاق الملفات التاريخيه الكبرى موضوع
يهوديه الدوله هو تكريس منظومه التفوق
العرق من جهه وتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه
والذهاب يعني بتوغل نحو اكبر
قوه وحضور للاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه
والامعان في الاحتلال وهنالك تربه خصمه
والتربه الخصبه هي الحاله التفقه العربي
وايضا يعني كما اعلن نتنياهو في خطاب
اليوم انه يسعى الى توسيع رقعه اتفاقيه
التطبيع وحاله التفوق الغربي تغني طبعا
يعني من قدره هذه الحكومه على الامعان في
سياساتها الاحتلاليه خصوصا ان اتفاقيات
قفزت عن الورقه الفلسطينيه ولم توضع كما
توضع في السابق كما كانت يعني هنالك عندما
كان هنالك اجماع عربي حول القضيه
الفلسطينيه وايضا العالم منشغل في قضايا
اخرى في غايه الاهميه ولكن ايضا اريد
التاكيد على بالله عليك ان العالم ينظر
الى اسرائيل كانها البنت الشرعيه للمواثيق
الدوليه من قرار التقسيم وحتى يومنا هذا
ولذلك لن يكون هنالك تدخل يعني دولي في
سياسات اسرائيل ويعني في اكثر يعني
الحالات تطرفا سيكون هنالك تمديد سيكون
هنالك استنكار ولكن يعني ايضا النقب التي
تضع نفسها بديلا لليمين في اسرائيل غيبت
قضيه الاحتلال والقضيه الفلسطينيه عن جدول
اعمالها في الحكومه السابقه ولذلك يعني
نار هنالك معانا في همم التوغل في السياسه
شكرا
الاسرائيليه من الناصره
اولويه الاستيطان لدى حكومه موضوع عن
سنبحث فيه اكثر بعد قليل ضمن فقره في
المتابعه
[موسيقى]
الى ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث دوله صباح
اليوم انفجارات في العاصمه
صاروخيه روسيه كفيفه ثلاث مناطق واسعه من
البلاد
مدينه اوداسه هما الاكثر تضررا
هذا واعلن حاكم مقاطعه سنتوفر روسيه ان
دفاعات الجويه الروسيه اسقطت الطائره
مسيره في منطقه انجلز حيث تقع القاعده
الجويه الروسيه التي تعرضت قبل ايام لهجوم
بطائرات مسيره
في اثناء اعلنها حكموا مقاطعه الروسيه ان
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اسقطت الطائره
مسيره من منطقه حيث تقع القاعده الجويه
الروسيه بينما استدعت بيلاروسيا السفير
الاوكرانيه لديها للاحتجاج على السقوط
صاروخ الاوكراني على اراضيها فيما لم
يستبعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان تكون
الخطوه استفزازا روسيا على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
ضمن تغطياتنا لاهم الاحداث التي شاهدتها
العمل
سياسيه واقتصاديه متواصله فقد فشل
البرلمان خلال عشر جلسات في انتخاب رئيس
جديد للبلاد ما ادخلها في حاله شهور
رئاسيه ويعود
الانتخاب الرئيس وتشكيل حكومه جديده وتنجز
الاتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدوليه
[موسيقى]
يختزل هذا المشهد في طرابلس شماليه لبنان
تداعيه الانهيار الاقتصادي في البلاد
فاوضاع المقيمين في حي الصفيح ماساويه في
ظل تعمق
الهويهم او اختاروا البحث عن حياه افضل
عبر قوارب باتت مرادفا للموت
هنا يمتزج الفقر مع انعدام مقومات العيش
الكريم كثيره هي القصص التي يمكن ان تروى
هنا نحاول التحدث الى البعض حجي خبريني عن
ظروفكم بشكل سريع اهلا وسهلا
انهيار الاقتصادي الذي يعانيه لبنان واقعا
شديد الصعوبه فسواد الاعظم من اللبنانيين
باتو من الفقراء وفق المنظمات الدوليه
ارتفعت كذلك اسعار السلع والمواد المختلفه
لا سيما الغذائيه منها على نحو غير مضبوط
وكل ذلك مرتبط
الليره اللبنانيه مقابل الدولار علما ان
الخسائر الماليه للبلاد قدرت باكثر من
سبعين مليارات دولار
وهذه الخسائر دفعت المصارف الى وضع قيود
على الودائع لديها فاستمرت للعام الثالث
الطوابير امام البنوك
اكثر من ذلك اقتحم مذيعون فروعا للمصارف
للحصول على اموالهم التي ظنوا ان هذه
مامنه وسيجدونها عند الحاجه اليها
يحصل كل ذلك على وقع ازمه سياسيه الشهور
الرئاسي عنوانها الاول في ظل عدم توافق
الاحزاب على شخصيه لتبوء سده الرئاسه
الى ما انتجته الانتخابات التشريعيه في
مايو الماضي من برلمان لا غلبه فيه لاي
طرف وتعطل بذلك المسار السياسي في البلاد
تركيبه البرلمان حال دون انتخاب الرئيس
رغما عقادي عشر جلسات لهذه الغايه فما كان
يعرف بفريق الثامن من اذار فقد الاغلبيه
علما ان خلافات تعصف بين بعض مكوناته اما
اطراف قوى الرابع عشر من اذار فحصده 40
مقعدا بينما توزعت المقاعد الباقيه على
نواب يوصفون بالتغييريين ومستقلين
ورغم حاله الاستعصاء السياسي هذه الجزاء
لبنان خلال العام الجاري ترسيمه حدوده
البحريه الجنوبيه بواسطه امريكيه واراعيه
اماميه
ملف الطاقه يعول لبنان على عائئته
المحتمله عبر استثمار ثروته من النفط
والغاز لتجاوز ازمته الاقتصاديه
ويترافق ذلك مع تعويلا داخليا على تسويه
بابعاد اقليميه ودوليه تشمل ملفات الرئاسه
والحكومه والاتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي
بما يوفر للبنان ضمانات خارجيه ومساعدات
ماليه لانتشاله من ازماته جونيتون تونس
الجزيره بيروت
وينضم الينا من بيروت ناصر ياسين وزير
البيئه اللبناني في حكومه تصريف الاعمال
مرحبا بك سيد ناصر
انطلاقا من تبعناه في هذا التقرير
هل اسقط في يد اللبنانيين جميعهم شعبا
وقياده وحكومه ومسؤولين عن ايجاد اي حل
لاي مشكله في البلد مهما كانت صغيره
لا يعني
التقرير اشار الى
الازمات المتعدده التي تعصف من لبنان ولكن
ايضا اشار الى بعض الامور الايجابيه التي
قامت بها حكومتنا خلال السنه الماضيه هناك
تاسيس
لمرحله تعافي كانت يجب ان همم تكون اسرع
من ما حدث خلال الاشهر الماضيه
وضعنا بعض الامور على السكه الصحيح منها
الاتفاق
الاولي مع صندوق النقد على مستوى الخبراء
اللي كان لازم بشكل سريع خلال هذا العام
بعد انتخاب مجلس النيابي يصير في تنفيذ
لبعض الاصلاحات واصدار قوانين تضع لبنان
همم يعني همم مرحله التوقيع الاتفاق
النهائي مع صندوق النهار لان هذا اساسي
ليس للدعم المالي الذي يحصل عليه لبنان و
سيحصل عليه لبنان عندما يوقع ولكن ايضا
اشاره الى المسار الاصلاح الذي يجب ان
يتبعه لبنان كحكومه وكما يعني انت تعرف ان
هذه ليست الخطه الاولى الاقتصاديه وليست
تفاوض الاول مع صندوق النقد وهناك قوانين
عاجزه لبنان عن اقرارها وماذا لا يحاول ان
يقرها لن ندخل في في هذه التفاصيل لكن
عمليه
لم يكن هناك حل لاي مشكله بل ان المشاكل
همم تعقدت وتعمقت اكثر الى حد العتمه
الشامله مثلا في البلاد وصولا الى العجز
حتى عن انتخاب رئيس
اللبنانيون يقولون نريد تدخل خارجيا
الجميع يتحدث بهذا المنطق فهل هل الجميع
ينتظر مبادره خارجيا للحل
لا المبادرات الخارجيه تساعد يعني خليني
افصل شوي موقفك استاذ العزيز ليست الامور
يعني بهذه السادويه كما تقول هناك اكيد
مشاكل وكلنا نعترف بتعدد الاسماك وصعوبه
حلها ولكن يجب ان نفصل بين عده انواع من
الاسماك على راس السنه هذه الازمات في
لبنان هناك ازمه سياسيه يجب نتفق على ذلك
هناك غياب للاستقرار السياسي الذي يؤدي
الى
صعوبه وضع حلول لكثير من القضايا منها
الكهرباء ومنها ما يتعلق بالموضوع المالي
والنقد والمصري ولكن يعني وضع كانه لبنان
انتهى كما تذكر صديقي العزيز يعني ليست في
مكانها وليس بالتحليل العلمي مع تاكيد على
صعوبه الوضع والازمات التي تمر بها
والمحاولات التي نقوم بها جميعا للصعود من
هذه الاسماء ولكن يعني لب هذه الازمه في
لبنان هو ازمه سياسيه هو عدم قدره
التيارات والاحزاب والفرقاء والقتل الان
في مجلس النواب على
القيام بابسط الامور بديهياتها وانتخاب
رئيس جمهوريه ضمن همم الاوقات الدستوريه
يعني خلال اسرع وقت خلال هذا هو الاساس
فنحن يعني نحاول تهدئه الوضع ابقاء بعض
القطاعات العمل مع المجتمع الدوليه
على المنظمات
لماذا لا ينجح لبنان
همم بانجاز اي امر من دون تدخل خارجي يعني
حتى تشكيله همم الحكومات انتخاب الرئيس
همم احيانا تشكيلات داخليه في لبنان يكون
فيها تدخل خارجي ولا تتم من دون رضا خارجي
لماذا ارجوك باختصار
هلا لا باختصار يعني لبناني هو دوله صغيره
تتعرض وتتاثر بكل ما يحيط بها من من
ديناميات تحصل على المستوى السياسي
والامني والعسكري والاقتصادي وهذا منذ
تاريخ نشوء لبنان منذ اكثر مئه عام ولكن
الرساله الاساس اليوم انه نحنا المجتمع
الدولي وحتى المجتمع العربي يريد ان يساعد
ولكن علينا ان نساعد الفتنه لن يتدخل احد
من ناحيه وضع يعني اتفاق للبنان ويقول له
روح انتخب هذا الرئيس او ذاك الرئيس يجب
ان نقوم احنا ك- قوه موجوده قوه سياسيه
وقوه في المجتمع على الحوار من بعضها
البعض لاصلاح بيتنا الداخلي وعلى راس هذه
الاصلاحات يبدا بانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه
هذا هو المطلوب وهذا ياتي بناء على حوارات
وعلى نقاشات يجب ان تحصل بين كل القوه
السياسيه اذا نحن مفكرين انه سننتظر القوه
الدوليه او بعض القوه الاخرى تقول لنا هذا
هو الاسم روح تنتخبوه هذا هو تبسيط لما
يعني كيفيه تعمل هذه الدول خاصه في هذه
اللحظه التي نحن فيها في العالم والصراعات
الموجوده والقضايا عالميا الموجوده التي
تبعد كثير من الدول عن لبنان وعن مشاكل
لبنان انه امر داخلي اكيد تاثر بالخارج
وتاثر بالاقليم نتاثر بما يحدث ولكن يجب
ان يكون هذا جزء اساسي واصلاح بيت من
الداخل الذي يبدا بانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه
طيب وهذا ما همم لم يحصل والتجارب السابقه
تدل ربما على عكس ذلك دائما كانت تدخل
للخارجي هو الذي ياتي
بالرئيس او حتى
بالحكومات لكن اود ان اتوقف عن نقطه همم
لها علاقه بالترسيم ترسيم الحدود البحريه
بين لبنان واسرائيل هذا امر في في ظل كل
المشاكل لبنان تم حله لان كانت هناك اراده
خارجيه همم بالفعل ولبنان استجاب بشكل او
باخر مع العلم انه يقول قد اخذ كامله
حقوقه التي طلب بها ماذا يدل ذلك
هذا يدل انه عندما يتم توافق في لبنان بين
القوه السياسيه نستطيع ان ننجز وانجزنا
ايضا الانتخابات وهذا السهره يمكن عن
التقرير الجزر الانتخابات النيابيه بدون
اي تدخل في هذه الانتخابات وجرت بشكل
ديمقراطي همم اتت بقتل واتت بعده يعني كما
ذكرت تقرير بعده اقليات همم لم يحصل احد
على اكثره وهذا اشاره جيده على طريقه
اداره العمليه الانتخابيه التي حدثت في من
قبل الحكومه فيعني بعض الامور عندما نتفق
بين بعضنا البعض عندما
يصبح اهداف واضحه وكل القوه السياسيه ترضى
انه نمشي بهذه النحو هذه الاهداف تنجح في
لبنان ننجح اكيد ضمن همم يعني احتضان
خارجي
لا يجب ان نكون مقصرين عن هذه الاتفاقات
لبدايه الانتخاب رئيس وغيره شكرا لك ناصر
ياسين وزير البيئه اللبنانيه في حكومه
تصريف الاعمال من بيروت
في نهايه حديثنا نوصلت الضوء على نتائج
الانتخابات البرلمانيه اللبنانيه الاخيره
وحصص الكتل السياسيه وما تبعها من شهور
رئاسي في العرض التالي
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده
والحديث عن الاستيطان حيث لم تدخل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه جهدا او سياسه
لتوسيع الاستيطان وقدم المزيد من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وتهجير اهلها الاصليين او هدم
بيوتهم
1967 وواحده نهايه عام 2017
اقيمت في انحاء الضفه الغربيه اكثر من 200
مستوطن في سنوات الاحتلال الاولى كانت
الاليه الاساسيه التي استخدمتها اسرائيل
للسيطره على الاراضي من اجل اقامه
المستوطنات هي وضع اليد على اراضي لاغراض
عسكريه ضمه حينها نحو واحد و 30,000 دينار
بين العملي
1979 و2002 طبق الاحتلال وقوانين الجديده
تسمح ببناء مستوطنات على اكثر من 900000
دونم وهي زياده بنسبه 170 بالمئه
يمتد عمران المستوطنات اليوم على مساحه
تفوق
500838,000 دينار وتشكل نحو عشره بالمئه
من مساحه الضفه الغربيه يضاف اليها اكثر
من مليون
و650,000 درهم هي مساحه نفوذ او مناطق
نفوذ المجالس الاقليميه للمستوطنات وتشمل
براري يا شاسعه لا تدخل في منطقه عمران اي
من المستوطنات وتبلغ مساحه الاراضي
الواقعه تحت السيطره المستوطنات مباشره
نحو 40 بالمئه من مجمل مساحه الضفه
الغربيه
مولانا من اريحا خليل تفجي الخبير في شؤون
الاستيطان سيد خليل مرحبا بك يعني امام
هذه الارقام ومع سياسه التوسع
والالتزام بان يكون هذا من اولويات حكومه
نتنياهو ال الجديده اين ستصبح اراضي الضفه
الغربيه اذا ما نفذت تلك السياسه
الاسرائيلي في هذا الموضوع لا يوجد دوله
فلسطينيه بل توجد تجمعات فلسطينيه في داخل
الضفه الغربيه
تحت السيطره الاسرائيليه بمعنى عباره عن
تجمعات فلسطينيه محاطه بالمستوطنات
اسرائيليه ترابط بينها عن طريق الانفاق
والجسور يعني دوله اا مواصلات او انفاق
وجسور اما دوله ذات تواصل الجغرافي غير
موجود وبالتالي الرؤيه الاسرائيليه واضحه
تمام بهذا الاتجاه ولا يخفى اي حزب من هذا
الموضوع بهذا الاطار بمعنى ان لا يوجد اي
دوله فلسطينيه هي عباره عن تجمعات
فلسطينيه
كبلديات دون ان تكون اي سياده لهذه
البلديات
طيب اين يتوقع ان يكون تركيز
الاستيطان من اجل تنفيذ هذا المشروع
الاسرائيلي الذي تشير اليه
هي عباره عن تطبيق مجموعه من المخططات
الاسرائيليه بدات في خطه الون يعني اقصد
هنا خطه الوانها هي منطقه الاغوار وهي
تعادل ثلث الضفه الغربيه ويجرى الان فيها
بشكل متسارع قضيه الراعي الراعي العبري
بمعنى احد الرعيان اليهود يسيطر على
مساحات كبيره وهو ما يطلق عليه اسم اكبر
مساحه ما اقل عدد من السكان اليهود في نفس
الوقت ايضا هي تطبيق لنظريات او تطبيق
لصفقه القرن لكن باسلوب اخر وهو فرض الامر
الواقع على الارض اولا بالنسبه للجانب
الاسرائيلي قضيه الاغوار بالدرجه الاولى
بدنا يتنازل عنها ثانيا في قضيه
المستوطنات ومناطق نفوذها وهي تعادل حوالي
60% من مساحه الضفه الغربيه لانه هنا
نتكلم عن المناطق المبنيه المناطق اللي هي
المخططات اللي هيكليه هذا كله يشمل منطقه
سي هو منطقه سياحيه تعاد
والباقي للجانب الفلسطيني حول 40% اذا
ماذا اينك تكون الدوله الفلسطينيه اذا
الجانب الاسرائيلي وضع كل المخططات في
داخل صفقه واحده وهي صفقه القرن وهي
بتوقيع الامر يعني نحن هنا نحن هنا نتحدث
عن مستوطنات جديده وليس فقط عن توسيع
المستوطنات ونتحدث عن قدر مزيد من الاراضي
همم يعني واقامه مستوطنات جديده عليها
هنالك 160 مستوطنه اسرائيليه كبيره ولديها
بناتها وايضا ما يجري الان في هذه المنطقه
هي ان كون نت وتشريع البؤر الاستيطانيه
وعددها حوالي 147
وبالتالي هذه تتحول الى مستوطنات او جزء
من مستوطنات الام يعني بمعنى اخر ان هذه
المستوطنه الام ستكون لها بناتها التي
تتوزع في جميع انحاء
الضفه الغربيه
شكرا جزيلا لك خليل التفجي الخدير في شؤون
الاستيطان حدثنا من اريحا
مشاهدينا بهذا ناتي الى نهايه الحصاد لهذه
الليله نشكر متابعتك